Les explications
de Mathieu Papillon.
♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est l'imagququi nous vient
en tête quand on parle de tests
PCR; un écouvillon et
qui n'a rien de particulièrement
agréable.
Mais pour ces scientifiques
de Pêches et Océans Canada, la
procédure deplplplplplplplplplp.
- C'est bon?- Oui.
- Avec une visite à la vivière
Little...
... pour prélever un p
échantillon d'eau.
Rien à voir, donc,vevec
la pandémie.
FRANCIS LeBLAN
Pêches et Océans Canada
- On est iciauaujourd'hui, pour
la détection de moules d'eau
douce en péril. Donc, une espèce
renflée. Donc, le but est
d'essayer de voi.... est-ce que
l'espèce est présente? Donc,
évaluer sa distribution,
identifier l'hcecececececececec.
- S'il y a cette sorte de moule
dans la rivière ici?
- Exactement, c'est bel et bien
visuellement la moule, on est
capable de détecter son ADN que
la moule relâche dans
de la rivière.
♪ ♪ ♪
On est ici, aujourd'hui, dans
moléculaire au Centre des pêches
du Golfe.
- Et c'est dans ce laboratoireau
filtrée sont traités.
CHANTAL GAUDREAU, techn., labo.,
Pêches et Océans Canadaltltltlta
aussi d'autres choses qui
restent captées sur le filtre.
Donc, nous, on vient faireononoe
sûr qu'on atteint l'ADN purifié
pour qonon soit capables de
le tester par après.
..c pls
- Donc là, on est rendus
àà l'étape du fameux test PCR,
c'est ça?
- Exactement. Ces instruments
ici vont nous permettre
de déterminer l'espèce en queste
est présent ou non. Donc, il va
y avoir une amplification
spécifique de l'ADN de l'espèce
qu
- De la moule qui nous
intéresse.
- De la moule d'eau douce en
Donc, le test PCR vient d'être
complété. On est capables
de voir ici, par la présenceunu,
qu'on a bel et bien détecté
l'ADN de l'alasmidonte renflée
au site, qui nous indique
la moule est fort probablement
présente dans la rivirere.
En mieux connaissant la science,
la distribution de l'espèce et
potentiellement l'habitat
de prendre des mesures pour
la protéger.
utilisés pour détecter
des pathogènes chez certains
poissons et crustacés, ou encore
espèce envahissante comme
le crabe vert.
- Le test PCR est juste dét déti
l'ADN ou l'ARN d'un organisme
quelconque est là ou non.
- Et comme tous les tests PCR se
accepté de contribuer
au dépistage de la COVID-19
quand la demande a atteint
des sommets.
- Tandis que notre travail
des pathogènes qui ne causent
pas de risques aux humains,
on a dû prendre des mesures
pr
mais le gros du travail...
on était hautement qualifiés
pour le faire.
- En contrepartie, l'évolution
la pandémie leur a aussi servis.
- Par exemple, la détection
de la COVID à partir
tout le travail pour optimiser
ces méthodes-là nous sert aussi
dans notre travail pour aller
détecter nos espèces
envahissantes.
- Ça a été un point positif
- C'est ça.
- Un des seuls.
- Un des
Un des seuls. Tu as ra